Hey office ladies family, guess what? We are done with season four. I can't believe it. I can't believe it. We're moving into season five, but we need a beat to prepare. Yeah, we need a week off. We gotta get our notes ready.
So we are gonna rerun grief counseling. You remember grief counseling? Season three, episode four. This was a great episode. A lot happens in this episode. We have audio clips from Jen Solada. We have an audio clip from Mindy Kaling's book. We have a twin absorption deep dive.
Yeah. I talk about poking some melons in France and Angela gets to the bottom of who is moving that conference table in and out of the conference room. I mean, it drove me crazy for years. You had to find out. We also have a special guest on this episode,
my daughter busts in while we were in the middle of recording. With an actual bird emergency. Yes. So guys, we thought this is perfect. It's spring again. I've got birds in a nest again at my house. I know me too.
So enjoy grief counseling and we're gonna see you next week with season five. Season five. Holy moly. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi everybody. Hello.
Welcome to office ladies. I'm so excited about this episode. It's so good, right? Yeah. And we reached out to lots of folks. So we have some fun, fun stuff. This is grief counseling. And guys, if we can get you depressed
by the end of this podcast, we've done our job. Oh, Michael. It's season three, episode four, written by Jen Salada and directed by Roger Nygaard. Jen Salada is one of my favorite people, Jenna. 100%. She is just such a delight and was so much fun on set
because she would always crack up. Oh yeah. She was one of our worst laughers which made her the best laugher. Yeah. Hey, Jenna, you know what I'd love right now? I hope it's a summary. It's a summary.
What? All right, here it is. Michael finds out that his former boss, Ed Truck, was decapitated in a self-induced drunk driving accident. Nobody seems upset though or certainly not upset enough which causes Michael to question if anyone would care about his death.
Of course, he doesn't know that that's what he's worried about. Yeah, he doesn't understand really the depths of his sadness. Yes. He wants everyone to love him and be sad for him if he wasn't around. Yeah, make a fuss about him.
Well, first he leads everyone in some grief counseling but then later he forces everyone to participate in a bird funeral. Meanwhile, over in Stanford, Jim is put in charge of supervising Karen for the day but decides to put their work on hold so they can search for her favorite bag of chips. Mm-hmm.
So we're gonna have so much to say about that. This is a really odd tangent and I don't mean to take this really weird, really fast. Do it. Jenna, while I was re-watching this episode, I hear a commotion outside of my, that's what she said. No. And a squirrel is eating a little bird.
That's worse than what I thought you were gonna say. Yeah, and so I was like, wait, what's he eating? What's he eating? I start filming it. I have video of me filming the squirrel and in the background, you can hear grief counseling and a bird funeral. Oh my God.
It was, like, it was so crazy. But apparently squirrels are like, they're like an opportunist, you know? If there's a little bird's nest, they go for a baby bird, they do it. Squirrels are terrible. Everyone thinks they're so cute because of their fluffy tails, but they're awful.
Look it up, everybody. Squirrels carry more disease than rats. Bleh. Look it up. Okay, sorry, but it just was kind of crazy that I was watching an episode that had a bird funeral and then I saw a squirrel attack a bird. It was crazy.
Yeah. Okay, how do we get back from that? Hit me with some fast facts. All right, fast fact number one. This episode was written by Jen Salado, we said that, and Angela reached out to Jen for this episode. Yes, Jen and I traded emails and texts and she was so much fun to talk to about this episode.
She was so excited to share information and so she sent in a whole bunch of audio clips that we are gonna play and she is gonna come back as a full, awesome guest for maybe two episodes coming up, Jenna. Ooh. Ooh, we're trying to figure out scheduling and whatnot, but she is in and I cannot wait.
Well, let's play her hello audio clip, Sam. Okay. Hey guys, it's Jen. I miss you. I'm loving your podcast. I am learning so much. I had no idea of the drama behind the scenes of Booz Cruise where you were floating away at Sea Angela
with Phyllis and Rain and Brian. Amazing. Anyway, I'm loving it and I'm gonna answer some grief counseling questions. So I'll send them in separate audio files. Isn't it nice to hear her voice, Ange? I love her voice. I find her voice really soothing.
Now listen, we were chatting back and forth and I was listening to her voice a lot. And Jen, I think you have real good podcast voice. I know. Jen, are you doing voiceover work? Like I'd buy anything you're selling with your voice. Or just call me and talk to me at the end of my day. Just leave me a message every day.
Just kind of telling me what you did. Yeah. Cause I will listen to that as I like do the dishes. I agree. And Angela, in one of the clips that Jen sent, she explains a little bit about the process of writing this episode for her, right? Yeah, it's so, it's so fascinating.
Sam, can you play it? Enjoy Jen's voice, everyone. One thing about this episode that really stuck with me personally was it was a thrill because it was hard to tell stories on other shows about characters going through internal things. And in this case with Michael, it was even more than that because this character was going through something internal
and he was unaware of it, which made it really exciting to write because I love internal stories, but it also made it kind of difficult to explain at times. And I remember that I created a little chart where it said, here's what Michael is doing and saying in the scene. And then in bold under it,
I wrote what was actually happening to Michael underneath it all. And of course, Steve got it all intuitively and he's a genius. It was such a treat to be able to write and tell that kind of story. And then Jenna, to have you be aware of what it was that was going on with Michael, to have Pam sort of sense it
and see it and fix it without it being spoken was just such a delight as a writer. Isn't that amazing? I love it. I love that she had like a secret notes and charts in her script about the emotional journey of characters. Yeah, I find all of that so interesting, just like the writer's process
and what she wrote and how then it ended up playing, you know? Oh my gosh, Angela, I just realized something. What? She was tracking. She was tracking Michael's emotional journey. She tracked it. All right, well, we are gonna hear more from Jen throughout the episode.
So Jenna, why don't you fast fact me? Okay, I'm calling fast fact number two, the big fight. Oh, you did a shoulder shimmy. I know, are you intrigued? I am. In Mindy Kaling's book, Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me? She writes a chapter about working on the office and being a writer and also being a performer.
And she said in her book that she and Greg Daniels got into such a huge fight during this episode that she stormed off the set. She kicked his car. Yes, yes, oh, that's so good, I forgot about that. But rather than have me read you the passage, Angela, wouldn't you rather hear it in Mindy's voice? Yes.
Well, guess what, there's an audio book. Oh, oh my God, oh my God, hit play, Sam, I wanna hear it. All right, here is the clip from the audio book of Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me and Other Concerns. It's published by Penguin Random House, LLC and read by Mindy Kaling. I tend to fight with Greg the most. My friend and fellow office writer, Steve Healy,
Well, guess what, there's an audio book. Oh, oh my god, oh my god, hit play, Sam, I wanna hear it. All right, here is the clip from the audio book of Is Everyone Hanging Out Without Me and Other Concerns. It's published by Penguin Random House, LLC and read by Mindy Kaling. I tend to fight with Greg the most. My friend and fellow office writer, Steve Healy,
believes it is because I am emotional and intuitive and Greg is more cerebral and logical. Or, as I like to think of it, I am a sensitive poet and Greg is a mean robot. Our fighting is legendary. One time, late at night, our script coordinator, Sean, and our head writer, Danny, both brought in their dogs and upon seeing each other,
they got into a violent barking fight. Paul Lieberstein glanced over and joked, oh, I thought that was just Greg and Mindy. What do we fight about? I wish I could say there were big, smart, philosophical issues about writing or comedy, but sometimes they're as small as, if we do that cold open,
where Kevin dumps a terrine of chili on himself, I will quit the show. We did that cold open, by the way, and it was a hit, and I'm still working at the show. I can get a little theatrical, which makes sense because after all, I came up through the theater, said in my snootiest masterpiece theater voice.
I will tell you about the worst fight we ever had. In a very heated rewrite session for the season three episode grief counseling, I was arguing with Greg so much, he finally said in front of all 12 writers, if you're gonna resist what I'm doing here, you can just go home, Mindy. Greg never sends anyone home or even hints at it.
Greg is the kind of guy who is so agreeable, I frequently find him on our studio a lot, embroiled in some long, boring conversation with a random person while his lunch is getting cold and his to-go container. And he's a boss. I would never talk to anyone if I was the boss. I would only talk to my attorney and my psychic.
So anyway, my very nice boss had just hugely reprimanded me. Greg suggesting I go home unless I adjusted my attitude was the harshest he'd ever been to anyone in the three years I'd been on the show. There was silence, no one looked at me. People pretended to be absorbed in their phones. One writer didn't even have a phone,
he just pretended to be absorbed in his hand. I was so embarrassed and angry that I got up, stomped out of the room, stole a 24 pack of bottled water from the production office, kicked the bumper of Greg's car and left the studio. Is that amazing? It's amazing. I love the detail that she took a 24 pack of water.
She was like, oh, I'm leaving, I am leaving. But I'm gonna be hydrated. Well, listen, she goes on to say that after this, she went to a nail salon to get a pedicure. And the woman asked her, oh, do you have the day off? And Mindy was like, no, my boss threw me out of work. And the woman was like, oh, you got fired? And that's when Mindy was like, oh, wait, wait,
what am I doing here? And she drove back to work and she told everyone she'd been in the bathroom. But Angela, she did keep that water. Good for you, Mindy. Her book is so fantastic. I own this book, it is hilarious, it is a great read. Mindy, thank you so much for letting us use
a little excerpt from it and you have to come on the show. And she is, guys, because I texted her and she's coming on, just wait. She's coming on, we won't say when, but it's happening. It's soon. You guys, if you're looking for entertainment right now, give it a try, the audio book is available on the Penguin House audio website and SoundCloud.com.
And thank you to Penguin Random House for letting us play the clip. I love knowing that this was going on in the backdrop of us filming this episode. You're kicking a car, you're taking water, Jen Salata's on set, cracking up. What is happening in the writer's room? Should we move on to Fast Fact number three?
I mean, I don't know how you beat one and two, but go for it. Well, I'm not sure I will, but I got a little scoop from Kentopedia about this episode. Ooh. All right, on the first shoot day of this episode, Kent reminded me that we had our big season three
photo shoot for NBC, where we did a big cast photo shoot, we did individual photos all in character. And since there weren't a lot of scenes happening in the break room, that's what we use for the photo shoot. I don't know if you remember it, Angela. I do.
They set up a desk and then they would switch out the props on the desk and we would take single photos. And I have this very stern, single photo of me holding a pencil and a pad of paper with a drawing on it that I've never felt properly represents the character of Pam, because I think I look like,
I think I look like a teacher who's ready to scold you in this photo, as opposed to a woman going through a life altering journey of love and expression. I have a photo of me looking very stern in a sort of a severe ponytail and I'm holding up a card with a cat on it. Well, then they took the desks away
and they loaded the break room with paper boxes and we all posed in front of them. Do you remember that one? I do because it was actually a very small space and when they got us all in there, they then couldn't figure out how to get us all in the photo. We were so jam-packed.
So they had tiered these boxes like a little pyramid and guess who had to crawl up to the tippity top and is at the very top and really I just look like a very tiny floating head in the way back of the photo. It's me. Well, then they moved us all over to the warehouse. Do you remember this?
And they made it rain paper on us. They blew paper in a giant fan. This was a little insane because it took, I mean, I can't even remember how many times to blow the paper. Yeah, I have a great photo from this day. I don't know who took it actually, but it's in between whenever they blew the paper in the air,
then they'd have to stop and reset it. Yeah, they'd have to pick up all the paper from the ground. Yeah, and then someone would have to bring it back and toss it back in the air, right? So it was like a 20 minute turnaround between these setups. And in between the setups, we all had to just stay there in the warehouse. We're like on the loading dock area, right?
Yeah. And I'm in my skirt and my blouse, my severe ponytail and I squat down, lady like in a skirt, did you know how you can tuck your skirt up in your leg and squat down so you're not ruining the mystery for anyone? Sure. Jenny, you said sure like you weren't sure.
I squat down in my Angela Martin outfit to talk to Paul Lieberstein. So there's this great photo of everyone sort of kneeling about in between this paper setup and I'm squatting down so completely out of character talking to Paul. I love it. Well, it was really crazy
because we would have to shoot these whole episodes but then also like when they would be setting up a new scene, we would run off to the warehouse and take pictures with the paper coming down on us. Yeah. It was a bizarre day. It was super, it was super bizarre. And when Kent wrote me and reminded me of that,
it all kind of came flooding back. Like, oh yeah, remember how weird that was? Yeah. Well listen, should we take a break and then get into this episode? Let's do it. Let's do it. All right, we'll be right back.
All right, so we're back. We are in the bullpen. That's what we would call the big main room where, you know, Michael would always come out and talk to everyone and he is doing a bit, guys. He has stacked up. Oh, he's got a bit. He has stacked up some boxes of paper.
Jenna, now that I remember that we were doing the photo shoot, I feel like those were the boxes that were in the break room that we took pictures on. I'm not even kidding. They very may well have been. So Michael's doing that classic like stairs or escalator bit, you know, where you stack up a bunch of stuff and then you slowly just kind of crouch down.
And Dwight thinks it is the funniest thing he's ever seen. Oh, Rain's reaction is like if you showed that to a five-year-old. Yeah, yeah. Utter glee and just this is the best joke he's ever seen. Ever seen. And also, he's laughing as if he's never heard of it. Yes, this is all leading him.
He made it to be an adult man and has never seen the fake stairs bit. But, you know, I think, you know, in this episode, Pam is a little bit of the gym. Pam has taken on the jokester role, right? Yeah. So Ryan and Kevin joined in. They asked him to get little things, like a pen, you know.
But then Pam, showing a little bit of Pam's ass, is like, how about a cup of coffee? How about you give me a cup of coffee? And Michael's like, ugh. Well, I have a lot to say about this cold open, Ange. Oh, I want to hear it. First of all, this was not the original cold open in the script.
Somebody has the original script. I've got a shooting draft of grief counseling. Let's hear it. The original cold open was in Stamford. And it involved, yeah, and it involved a coworker of Jim wanting him to look at photos of her baby. Oh, oh, I saw this in a deleted scene. And she gets really put out with him,
because she shows him a picture of her husband and the baby in the bathtub. And Jim is like, finds it off-putting. He's like, oh, god, they're in the bathtub. And she's like, oh, you know what? Come back to me when you have kids, OK? She gets really mad at them. Well, this was the original cold open.
This cold open was added later. And we shot it at the end of the week, because it was an ad. And we had all those boxes. We had all those boxes from our photo shoot. Oh, my gosh. I wonder if they were inspired. They were like, wait, I know what we can do with these boxes. We have all these boxes just stacked
in the middle of the soundstage. We got it. Yeah. A lot of people wrote in and said, oh, my gosh, how many takes did you guys do of this cold open? Because if you notice, Steve looks like he's like sweating when he brings him her coffee.
He is sweating his butt off. He is so tired. Kent told me we did 10 takes 10 times. And every time we did a take, Steve went up and down the stairs three times. Oh, my god. So he did that 30 times. He was getting like a major like one of those like your quads
says the person who never works out. What are those called? Your quads. He was getting like he was probably some quad and glute. Quad and glute. And then he had to crawl around. Any wonder of poor guy. And Kent also told me that we actually
did six different camera setups for this scene because they had to move the camera in different places to do the shot when he's crawling, when he goes inside the kitchen for his talking head, which is technically part of it. So yeah, but he walked up and down the stairs 30 times. Oh, my gosh, Steve, your butt. It must have been so sore.
Well, I have two little things in this opening scene. First of all, at 51 seconds, I think Angela kind of smiles. Oh. When Pam says get a cup of coffee, Angela kind of has a smile. Like there is a brief moment where I think she's on your side. I just wanted that to be documented. Oh.
And then I have a great fan catch at 1 minute, 27 seconds. Ready for this? Yeah. Kelly and Chloe Harrigan and Shannon Rajowski, they wrote in and they noticed that when Michael returns from the kitchen when he's crawling on the ground, that that is Jim's coffee mug. That's the coffee mug that Jim always uses.
Oh, my gosh, yes. Isn't that a great catch? And I was like, I wonder if that was a little nod to Jim so that Jim's presence got to be in Scranton for a little moment. I love that. Great catch, guys. Great catch. All right, so then we move into Michael's office.
And he's on the phone with Jan, who informs him that they have lost Ed Truck. And then Michael's like, well, I have his number somewhere. I can find it for you. Yeah. And she's like, no, Michael, Ed Truck has died. He goes out into the room. He breaks the news to everybody.
Kelly rushes up, gives him a hug. Oh, we have a special appearance by Kelly's extensions and her bangs. They make a special appearance. They are hugging Michael, giving him some comfort. And then Michael approaches Pam for a little awkward hug. So awkward. And, lady, I have a track moment.
I'm tracking it. I'm tracking it. What are you tracking? You know I love to track the plants at front reception. Are there more new plants? Well, whatever happens to them, they make an appearance and then we never see them again. At three minutes, 29 seconds, I am pretty sure
that's a succulent. We have a succulent. Suculent alert. Suculent alert at front reception. We'll probably never see it again. But when Michael hugs Pam awkwardly, you get a nice shot of that succulent. I'm not kidding.
I really need to start a spreadsheet. A really complex spreadsheet. All the things we're tracking. Well, next we move over to the Stanford office. And a staff meeting becomes very awkward when Josh is super sexist and condescending to Karen. Oh, he was. He's sort of just totally dismissed her.
What a search. I know. Yeah, seriously. And then he puts Jim in charge of her for the day. Oh, gross. Oh my gosh. Gross, Josh. This is like a physical representation
of mansplaining, I feel like. Yeah. You know what? Jim, why don't you check in on that? Yeah, why don't you oversee that, Jim? Why don't you check in on that? And she's like, yeah, thanks. Yeah, thanks.
Yeah, thanks. Well, we had a fan catch from Brandon. He says, at 3 minutes and 42 seconds, when Karen is flipping through her stack of papers, I think I see a page from the script in her note. Oh, oh, that's such a good catch. You do. I froze it.
Oh, yeah. She's got a little script page. We used to do that. Remember, Ange, we used to hide script pages in our notebooks. I used to keep them in a drawer. Like, in between takes, I would open my drawer and I would be like, OK, wait, did I get it? Did I get it to get it?
And then I shut my drawer again. Yes, we had scripts hidden everywhere on that set that we could just peek at between scenes to make sure we were on our lines or if we wanted to prep right before. I mean, obviously, we had worked on them and we knew our lines. But when you're doing a bunch of takes, sometimes you're like, oh, wait, crap, what was that?
And you just want to do a quick peek. But also, you know, they would have their writer's draft and then we would read it at a table read and then they would make a bunch of changes and they would start on Monday with what was called the shooting draft. And that's what I have. I have a bunch of shooting drafts left over.
But every single morning we would arrive to work and there would be a stack of new pages. They were rewritten scenes just for that day. They would hand you the pages sometimes that morning and be like, OK, here we go, guys. These are your changes for the day. You better believe we were hiding pages in our desks and notebooks.
But yes, Brandon, you saw one. That just tickled me because that is so true. That was a good catch. OK, so now at four minutes, two seconds, Karen is really disappointed, you guys, because the chips that she likes, they're not in the vending machine. But I think Jim felt bad at the way Josh treated her
and he now wants to make amends, right? He wants to try to help her find these potato chips. And this whole scene about Karen and her potato chips just got me thinking about Rashida's breakfast order. OK, do you remember her breakfast order? No. OK, well, we often were in hair and makeup together at the same time.
And I texted her because I was like, Rashida, I totally just had this memory of your breakfast order. Here was the great thing about our caterer, Sergio. First of all, he was amazing. But if your order became kind of popular, if other people liked it, you would get your name on the menu. Yes. So you would walk up to the truck to order
breakfast in the morning, the food truck, and you could order a Rashida Angela size. Because I always wanted everything half portion, because it was just big. The portions were big and I'm a little person. So I'd always say, can I have half of that? So they started calling it Angela size. So here's what the Rashida was.
And Sergio, I ran into Sergio a while back because I was working on a Netflix show and he was the caterer for it. For Mindy's show, never have I ever. He was the caterer. Yeah, Mindy hired him, which was fantastic. We had a little mini-office reunion. And here's the Rashida, which you can still order from Sergio.
Ready? Yes. A corn tortilla, poached egg, black beans, avocado, turkey bacon, chalula on the side. And I was texting with Rashida about it, and she was like, I don't even know how I functioned after eating that. Like, why should I have just gone and taken a nap? But that's called the Rashida.
But I can get that Angela size if I'm not that hungry. Yeah, I'd like the Rashida Angela size, please. Oh, my gosh, that brought back so many memories. Molly Neck wrote in to say, guys, you can see her favorite chips in the vending machine Slot B1. OK, so there's a row of potato chips in the vending machine. But apparently, those aren't the ones that Karen wants. Yes, Karen wants salt and vinegar potato chips.
I did a mini deep dive on hers potato chips. And Philadelphia Magazine did a ranking of all the hers potato chips, and salt and vinegar was their number one chip. So it might make sense that it was hard to find, because it's the number one chip. Close behind was Cheddar horseradish, Pam's favorite sour cream and onion was number four.
Our favorite is their barbecue chips. I love their hers barbecue chips. I don't know where that is in the ranking. On the ranking? OK. I'm sorry, I didn't look that one up. OK. But I do have a script catch for you as well.
We're not done talking about this yet. In the shooting draft of the script, her favorite chips were going to be salsa verde Doritos. Wow. So here we go. We're going back to Scranton, and Creed is in Michael's office. With Dwight and Michael. And he tells them that Ed was decapitated.
And Michael's like, what? And he goes, yeah. He was flying down the road. He'd been drinking. And I guess he ran into a semi truck, right? And was decapitated. Yeah. Angela, we got a lot of mail about this scene with Creed.
OK. There is a very, very big debate online over whether or not Creed the character is making it up that Ed was decapitated, or if it's the truth. The truth within the show. And you know, Creed told some crazy stories, both on camera and off camera. So I can see where this sort of like controversy,
if you will, around Creed's retelling of this. Is it true? Is it not? Fiona, Danielle, Kelly, Danny, Mackenzie, Adam, and Valerie. They all said, how did Creed know the details of Ed Truck's death if Michael was the first to know from corporate? So their theory is that Creed's making it up because there's no possible way for him to know more details
than Michael. And then Maria pointed out that Creed lies later in another episode and says that Dwight was decapitated. That's in the episode, The Return. So she's like, maybe Creed is just obsessed with decapitation because he's a weird character? I don't know. Well, here's the thing.
I love that you guys were all writing back and forth about this. I think that because Creed knew Ed, he actually knew Ed. Maybe there was someone he called. But we decided, hey, let's go to the source. Let's ask Jen Solada. Was this story made up by Creed the character or was it truth in the sort of scope of the show? Did this really happen?
So here's what Jen had to say. Did Ed Truck really get decapitated? Sadly, for Ed Truck, he did really get decapitated. It sounds like a Creed story, but it actually was a true story in the world of our show. There is no Ed Truck and he didn't really lose his head. However, in the world of the office, he did get decapitated for real.
I think it was Greg that came up with the decapitation. I can't quite remember and Greg can't remember, but I remember spending a lot of time talking about the way Michael's former boss would die and how it had to be something very sudden and jarring so that it could be a shock to Michael Scott's system that he could just freak out one day because he's just living his life and going into the office
and then all of a sudden he could be dead. So I think that is where the decapitation came from. Unfortunately, I also can't remember who came up with, his capacitated from his head. I feel like it wasn't me because I would have been really proud of it if it was me and I'd remember that. But yeah, the decapitation was real for Ed Truck.
Sorry, Ed Truck. There you have it. Ed Truck really got decapitated. Creed actually got some facts that Michael didn't know. This is the slippery slope with Creed and let me tell you, this is true in real life and as this character, he'll say something and you're like, that's not true.
And then it's 100% true. And then he'll say something else and it's total BS. Yes. Welcome to the world of Creed. That is true. Well, after this, Michael decides to break the news to the whole office. I love the little couplet.
I just loved it. I watched it over and over of Michael being like, I don't know how to tell you this. And then Dwight is like, Ed Truck was decapitated. And Michael's like, what are you doing? He's like, you said you didn't know how to say it. You said you didn't know how to say it. Dwight is so literal, right?
So literal, yeah. Oh my God. It made me laugh so hard too. Well, lady, I want to talk about something in this scene because at five minutes, 38 seconds, I wrote down Angela's face. What'd they do? I feel like in this moment,
you have what I would consider to be a quintessential Angela reaction. You made so many sour faces on our show and they are so funny to me because I never see you make these faces in real life. They are so not your personality, but they have been turned into memes. You are known for this just disapproving look.
But it's like, it's just funny to me because in real life, you are nothing like this. You know, people write in and say, oh, you have resting bitch face. You've heard that expression, right? RBF. But now they're just calling it resting Angela Martin face.
It's like resting Angela face. But this is cracking me up right now, like in a whole different way because I am doing this show called Be Our Chef. You know, I'm hosting this family cooking competition. Lady, you know I know this. We watch it. We watch it religiously.
Thank you. My kids love this show. You guys, it's a cooking show. It's on Disney Plus. You have to watch it. It's families cooking and competing. And Angela is the host and it is just the sweetest, most uplifting,
most just pure fun. Oh, that is so sweet. Here's the thing my family is doing. So you're saying that you froze on my face making the sour face? My family keeps doing like freezing the screen when I'm making the weirdest faces. I guess in Be Our Chef,
I have learned that I talk really animated and I move my hands around and it's like I'm Jim Carrey. My kids think I look crazy most of the time on Be Our Chef. And their favorite thing now is to screen grab it and text me. I'm loving it.
And Angela, I have to say this last Friday when it came on, I was like, guys, guys, we're going to watch Be Our Chef and Angela's on and my daughter goes, you really love Angela. Aw. She is your best friend. And I said she is my best friend.
Aw, that is so sweet. I know, I know. That is so sweet. Okay, so yes, I make weird faces everybody. I make weird faces. While we're talking about my weird faces, Jenna, in the scene, we're Dwight asked Angela to put his head on ice, right?
Oh, yes. Okay, this is around five minutes, 44 seconds. Right at the top of the scene, I'm getting something out of the vending machine. Did you notice my jacket? Yeah, lady. I have the same time code. Five minutes, 44 seconds, I wrote,
Angela Wardrobe, what's up? I know. What is up with your very odd, short-sleeved jacket? What is this item? It is a short, it's a... Can it be purchased or was this made for you? I think someone purchased it
or found it in a warehouse like NBC. But it is a short-sleeved pinstriped, kind of like a dress jacket. And I jokingly called it to Wardrobe, my Janet Jackson jacket. Because do you remember, I loved Janet Jackson. And do you remember Rhythm Nation, her album Rhythm Nation?
Yeah. Okay, watch the music video of the song All Right. She is wearing this pinstriped jacket. Of course, mine was short-sleeved, hers was like regular. But we jokingly called this to the Wardrobe department, my Janet Jackson jacket. I don't know. It was so weird.
It was weird. It was like short-sleeve. I'm sorry to whoever designed it, but it's like your short-sleeve blouse is peeking out underneath your short-sleeve jacket. It's an odd design. It's a total mess. It's a total mess,
but it makes me laugh to look back on it. It a little bit reminds me of something that you might see on Project Runway when they had to make a jacket out of another jacket. But it had to not... They had to reimagine the jacket. Reimagine the jacket. And they just made it a short-sleeve jacket,
and they were voted off. Yeah, pretty much. All right, guys. So then we have a pretty adorable Dwight talking head where he says that he wants to be frozen when he dies, even if they have to do it in pieces, even if he is decapitated, he wants to be frozen
because he will wake up stronger than ever, and he will have been able to use that time to figure out how he died and how he could have better defended himself. Yeah. Yeah, he's thought it through. He's thought it through. But Angela...
I love talking heads. Angela does not want to participate in this. She doesn't want to. No. No. So now Michael is on the phone with Jan, and he really doesn't understand why they have a day honoring Martin Luther King
when he didn't even work at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. But Ed Truck, Ed Truck sat at his same desk and has died, and Jan's like, okay, listen, do you want to just give everyone the day off? And he's like,
you don't get these people. They wouldn't want that. No, they don't want to go home. What they want is a robot statue of Ed Truck. The eyes light up. Yeah. That's what they want. Well, we had a fan question here from Sierra.
When Michael is on the phone with Jan and has an article with a picture of himself and Ed on the desk in front of him, he slowly drags the corner of an envelope down to cover Ed's head, you know, because he's been decapitated. Was that scripted? Yes.
That action was scripted. It was in the script. And then, of course, you see the camera made sure to capture it. So smart. So smart. So thought out. Well, I really thought Dwight's drawing of the robot
with the six foot extension cord to the wall so it couldn't attack him. I thought that was fantastic. And smart. I wanted to know who drew it, but we probably don't know, do we? We don't know. We had fan questions about that, too, Ann.
And I tried to find out, but I couldn't get the answer for you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think it was rain. I don't think it was rain. She drew it in the back just quickly on a notepad. I'm sure.
But I feel like I can say with 99% certainty it was not rain. I feel like rain might have doodled on it during the scene, but the original drawing was not rain. Yes. Okay. Now we have to go back over to Stanford. I actually texted Ed Helms.
I said, Ed, you just made me do the snort laugh so hard because here we are. Jim and Karen are still trying to find these chips. They're having a hard time, but Jim's like, we're not going to quit. And she's like, I'm not a quitter. And then Andy's like, what's the game? What are we playing?
I'm in. And then they tell him we can't find the chips. And he's like, did you check the vending machine? And they're like, oh, no. Actually, we checked the fax machine. And you see how pissed off Andy gets at them because he knows. He knows they're being smart asses. And he just looks at them so seriously and goes,
did you check your butt? It made me laugh so loud. It made me laugh so hard. I like watched it twice back to back. So I was like, oh my God. And then I texted Ed. I said, Ed, you are so funny in this scene. I texted him the line and he was like,
we were like trading texts about it, just cracking up. Well, that line is in the script. I went and looked. I had to know. But I don't know if you noticed in this scene, seven minutes, 35 seconds. The smile post-it is gone from Jim's computer. You've been tracking that post-it, lady.
I've been tracking it. All right. And I don't know if you notice. I mean, he's acting more like Jim now, right? Like he's got a little thing. He's dazzling a lady with his charm. He's getting more comfortable. Yeah, he's more comfortable.
And he has an adventure within work, right? That's kind of like, this is a boring job to Jim. So he always has to find a distraction to get him through the day. Jim's the guy who makes work more fun, right? With his little things like this that he does. So he's back to his old ways. Back at the Scranton branch, Michael is just obsessed now.
He just can't stop thinking about Ed Truck. And he's really starting to internalize it about himself, right? Like, what if I were gone? No one cares here. No one cares. And he decides that they probably need some grief counseling. They're in denial. Yeah.
Yeah, he wants us to know the stages of grief. And he feels like it's his job to take us through them. He doesn't know if he can get us all the way to acceptance, but if he can get us depressed, he will have done his job. It's such a great line. It's such a good line. I have a really great little tidbit right here. What is it?
Okay, so in the deleted scenes, Toby is actually a trained grief counselor. Okay. And so, you know, Dwight's like, Toby should probably lead us through this. He's a trained grief counselor. And Toby starts to walk them through the steps. They're in the conference room.
And Michael's like, oh, you're ruining everything. It's going to take me forever to undo what you've done. And of course, Toby was being perfectly normal and appropriate. Right? Yes. Michael's like, you're ruining it. And this whole scene is in the conference room taking place around the conference table.
Everyone's sitting there. And Michael's like, that's it. I'm going to have to fix everything you've ruined, Toby. Ryan, Dwight, take the conference table out. We're going to take a five minute break while they reset. And we're coming back in here. And I'm going to lead you in grief counseling. And I about fell out of my chair because in my knowledge,
that is the first time we have ever referenced the dang conference table. Oh my gosh. And now we know who's always moving it. It's Dwight and Ryan. Dwight and Ryan. Where they put it, I don't know. We don't know.
It was the first time I ever heard Michael say, OK, let's get the conference table out of here. Yes. Acknowledging that the conference table can be removed and replaced. On a whim. How do they get it out of the doorway? I don't know. They probably have to take it apart.
But Michael's like, we're going to take five to 10 minute break. And when we get back in here, we're going to get down to it. And then the next scene is them with the little ball that they're about to toss around. But that's a deleted scene that sets it up. I love that. I love that. Well, listen, why don't we take a break?
And then when we come back, we will meet Michael in the conference room for some of his grief counseling. Yeah, and maybe. Sound good? Maybe Roy will stop by. Who knows? He might. Because Pam might need a little break as well.
All right, we'll be right back. And we're back. Here we are. Angela, what did you do during the break? I went and got an iced tea, Jenna, and I said hi to my husband. And I walked up, I guess, behind him kind of quietly and I scared the crap out of him. Oh boy.
That's what I did on my break. And he was like, hey, he was like, why does it get me so tickled? I don't know why spooking him makes me laugh so hard. I got a cup of coffee and then I put the sheets from the washer into the dryer. And I'm all excited that I'm podcasting and doing the laundry at the same time because you know I love a good multitasking. Oh yeah.
Oh, I have laundry going, lady. I started in the morning. Oh, it's going. Okay. It's also, I find that when I do laundry, I can't podcast in my closet because you can hear the dryer. Sure. So on the days I do laundry, I podcast in my shed.
There you go. There you go. Making it work. Podcasting from home. I'm in my pajamas. I never said that at the beginning. Oh, I noticed. I didn't say anything, but I noticed.
I did my hair though. I don't know what that says about me. I like it. When my hair is done, I feel good even if I'm still in my pajamas. There you go. All right guys, we are back in the conference room and Michael is going to lead us in some grief exercises. It involves taking a ball.
And when you have the ball, you can talk about a moment of grief in your life. Michael goes first. Yeah. Of course. Michael goes first. And he talks about Ed Truck. Angela, when he says his feelings about Ed Truck, it's so good.
He goes on and on. I asked Sam to pull a clip so that we could all listen to it together. Oh God. I'm so happy about this because I wrote in my journal that in this scene, this particular like moment, we could not get through. And lady, it's not in the script. This was, I think, an improvisation by Steve. Oh my God.
Oh God. Okay. Well, there's one line. I'm not going to say it yet. Let's listen to it. There's one line that I wrote in my journal. We all disintegrated. Mom.
Oh my God. Wait. Hold on. What is it, baby? Sunny got a bird. Oh, okay. Hold on. I'll be right back.
Okay. He got one of the doves. Yeah. And what's happening? Got a bird. Sunny is their cat. So here's the thing. This podcast started with me telling about a squirrel that ate a bird.
好吧。他抓到了一只斑鸠。是的。然后发生了什么？抓到了一只鸟。桑尼是他们的猫。所以事情是这样的。这个播客开始于我讲述了一只松鼠吃了一只鸟。
And now their cat just got a bird. I'm telling you, this is the bird funeral podcast. Okay. Okay. I'm so sorry. I'm back. What happened? What happened?
现在他们的猫刚抓了一只鸟。我跟你说，这就是鸟类葬礼播客。好吧。好吧。非常抱歉。我回来了。发生什么事了？发生什么事了？
You guys, we got a grocery delivery and Sunny shot out the door. And I guess caught a bird, right? This is so insane that we're doing this episode right now. And Angela, you had a squirrel eating your bird when you were prepping. I had a squirrel eating a bird. Now your cat has like attacked a bird. Okay. But listen, it's good news.
各位，我们收到了杂货配送，桑尼冲出了门。我猜它抓了一只鸟，对吧？我们现在正在录制这一集，这真是太疯狂了。安吉拉，你准备的时候也有一只松鼠在吃鸟。我有一只松鼠在吃鸟。现在你的猫又袭击了一只鸟。好吧。但是听着，这是好消息。
I have good news. We caught Sunny. We wrestled him to the ground. We got the bird out of his mouth and it's a pretty big bird and he was unharmed. The bird was unharmed. You saved the bird. The bird's okay. Michael would be so happy.
我有好消息。我们抓住了桑尼。我们把他按倒在地。我们从他嘴里把鸟掏出来，这是一只相当大的鸟，而且它没有受伤。这只鸟没有受伤。你救了这只鸟。这只鸟没事。迈克尔一定会很高兴的。
What's going to happen next week for the initiation? I don't know. I don't want to be initiated, Jenna. No. I don't want it. Please. Don't bring that over here. I don't want any of that.
下周的入会仪式要发生什么？我不知道。我不想加入，珍娜。不。我不要。求你了。别把那个拿过来。我一点也不想要。
Okay. All right. Well, that was crazy. So sorry. I can't believe this is all happening in grief counseling. Okay. Where were we? All right.
好吧。好吧。嗯，这太疯狂了。非常抱歉。真不敢相信这一切都发生在悲伤辅导中。好吧。我们刚才说到哪了？好吧。
Let's play this clip of Michael talking about his grief of Ed Truck. I lost Ed Truck. And it feels like somebody took my heart and dropped it into a bucket of boiling tears. And at the same time, somebody else is hitting my soul in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer. And then a third guy walks in and starts punching me in the grief bone. And I'm crying and nobody can hear me because I'm terribly, terribly, terribly alone. Angela, can I guess the line that we couldn't get through? Yeah.
让我们播放这段迈克尔谈论他失去埃德·特克的悲伤的片段。我失去了埃德·特克。这感觉就像有人掏出我的心，把它扔进了一桶沸腾的眼泪里。与此同时，另一个人正用一把冷冻的大锤砸我的灵魂的裆部。然后第三个人走进来，开始捶打我的悲伤之骨。我在哭，但没人听得见，因为我太孤独、太孤独、太孤独了。安吉拉，我能猜出我们怎么也过不去的那句台词吗？是的。
Is it frozen sledgehammer? I put every one of us broke when he said that his soul was getting hit in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer. Yes. Yes. That's what I wrote in my journal. I said we could not keep it together. Okay.
是冷冻大锤吗？我敢说我们每个人听到他说他的灵魂被冷冻大锤砸中裆部时都笑场了。是的。是的。这就是我在日记里写的内容。我说我们根本控制不住自己。好吧。
I said that's not in the script. I don't know if he was handed that rewrite on the day, but it feels like that's a Steve. That's a Steve improv. That feels like Steve to me. Oh, man. Man, man. That got us good though. Oh, man.
我说剧本里没有这句台词。我不知道他是不是当天才拿到这个修改剧本，但这感觉像是史蒂夫的风格。这是史蒂夫的即兴发挥。我觉得这很有史蒂夫的风格。哦，天哪。天哪，天哪。不过这把我们整得够呛。哦，天哪。
That is so good. Well, then Roy walks in. There's a problem with Pam's car. Can she come down to the parking lot and take a look at it? Oh, yeah. So there is an extended scene of this in the deleted scenes. So if you thought it was awkward enough, their conversation by the car, it's extended and even more awkward.
这太棒了。然后罗伊走了进来。帕姆的车出了点问题。她能去停车场看一看吗？哦，是的。所以被删减的片段里有一个加长版的场景。所以如果你觉得他们在车旁的对话已经够尴尬了，那加长版就更尴尬了。
Jenna, here's my question for you. How did Roy know that she was stuck in the conference room? How? How did he know there was grief counseling? How? Oh. Okay. I think you're implying that she called Roy and told him about it.
珍娜，我有个问题要问你。罗伊怎么知道她被困在会议室里的？怎么知道的？他怎么知道这里有悲伤辅导？怎么知道的？哦。好吧。我想你的意思是她打电话给罗伊并把这件事告诉了他。
I'm implying. How did he know? How did he know? Okay. I have a take on it. I think Michael called Daryl down in the warehouse and said, bring everyone up for some grief counseling. And Daryl was like, no.
我的意思是。他是怎么知道的？他是怎么知道的？好吧。我有一种看法。我认为迈克尔打电话给仓库里的达里尔，说让大家都上来做点悲伤辅导，达里尔说，不去。
No. Well, that, that would explain it. Yes. That would explain it. We had a fan question from Alexa Porter. Was there ever talk of putting Pam and Roy back together? Or was it all just a setup to mess with our feelings? Well, there was talk in the writer's room that maybe Roy could win Pam back.
不。嗯，那，那就说得通了。是的。那就说得通了。我们有一个来自亚历克萨·波特的粉丝提问。有没有人讨论过让帕姆和罗伊复合？还是这纯粹是个捉弄我们感情的设定？嗯，编剧室里确实讨论过罗伊也许能把帕姆追回来。
Remember, David Denman was made a series regular for season three. Yeah. So he's going to be making a lot of appearances this season. I can tell you guys, nothing was decided at this point about what would happen with Jim and Pam, what would happen with Pam and Roy. They were feeling it out week to week. I totally remember that. I also remember it was constantly said that maybe, maybe in the series of the office,
记住，大卫·丹曼在第三季被升为常规演员。是的。所以他这一季会频繁亮相。我可以告诉大家，在这个时候，关于吉姆和帕姆会怎么样，帕姆和罗伊会怎么样，还没有做出任何决定。他们是走一步看一步。我完全记得这一点。我还记得当时经常有人说，也许，也许在《办公室》这个剧集里，
Jim and Pam would not end up together in the end, but would instead lead one another to their actual true loves. There was, it had not been decided right now that Jim and Pam were one another's true loves. When you just said that, I got angry. Oh no. I was like, no, Jim and Pam end up together. No. Oh.
吉姆和帕姆最终不会在一起，而是会各自引导对方找到他们真正的真爱。当时，并没有决定吉姆和帕姆就是彼此的真爱。你刚才这么说的时候，我生气了。哦，不。我当时想，不，吉姆和帕姆最后必须在一起。不。哦。
Well, I think maybe that's why the writing of their characters felt so authentic because the writers were figuring out their relationship at the same time that Jim and Pam were. Yeah. So we're, as an audience, we feel that like what will happen? We don't know. These are two people on journeys trying to find themselves and hopefully that leads them back to each other. Exactly.
嗯，我想这也许就是为什么他们角色的剧本写得如此真实，因为编剧们在吉姆和帕姆摸索关系的同时，也在摸索他们的关系。是的。所以作为观众，我们能感受到那种“接下来会发生什么？”我们不知道。这是两个在旅程中试图找到自我的灵魂，希望这能让他们重新回到彼此身边。 exatamente。
All right. So while Pam and Roy are out in the parking lot, I'm sure Pam was really hoping that she's going to come back to the like conference room and the grief counseling is almost over. But no, they waited for her because they're a family. I love that DT. They waited for her. Yes. There's a great scene on the DVD.
好吧。所以当帕姆和罗伊在停车场时，我确信帕姆真的很希望她回到会议室时，悲伤辅导已经快结束了。但并没有，他们一直在等她，因为他们是一家人。我太喜欢DT了。他们一直在等她。是的。DVD里有一个很棒的场景。
It's a deleted scene and Michael is trying to get everyone to loosen up, right? For the grief counseling, he's like, hey guys, take your jackets off, loosen your ties, take off your shoes, ladies, let your hair down. And Angela goes, I don't think Kevin should take off his shoes. Oh, and Kevin gets really annoyed. And then he has a talking head that he says, all right, listen, I have hyperhydrosis, okay? So we find out that he has this disease that makes your feet sweat really, really badly. So I guess he's been taking his shoes off over and accounting.
那是一个被删减的片段，迈克尔试图让大家放松下来，对吧？对于悲伤辅导，他说，嘿，伙计们，脱下外套，解开领带，脱下鞋子，女士们，把头发放下来。然后安吉拉说，我认为凯文不应该脱鞋。哦，凯文觉得很烦。然后他有一个单人访谈镜头，他说，好吧，听着，我有多汗症，好吗？所以我们发现他有这种让脚出汗非常非常严重的疾病。所以我想他在会计部门那边一直把鞋脱掉。
I love this little tidbit and I'm sad it didn't make it in. Well this explains why when Pam walks into the room, Kevin's feet are up on her chair and his shoes are off. Yes, people wrote in and asked about that. It's because in the deleted scene, Michael is getting everyone to loosen up and we find out that Kevin has, how do you say it? Hyperhydrosis. Angela, I love that.
我很喜欢这个小花絮，而且很遗憾它没有被剪进正片里。这就解释了为什么当帕姆走进房间时，凯文的脚搭在她的椅子上，而且鞋子是脱掉的。是的，有人写信来问过这件事。这是因为在被删减的片段中，迈克尔让大家放松下来，我们发现凯文有，你是怎么说的？多汗症。安吉拉，我太喜欢这个了。
That's a good catch. That's a good catch, good tip. Tidbit. Tidbit. It's a Kenzie tidbit. All right, so when Pam does finally get back, they begin again and Dwight is the first one to share. Oh, this is one of my favorite things.
这是个好发现。这是一个好发现，好小贴士。小花絮。小花絮。这是一个肯齐的小花絮。好吧，所以当帕姆终于回来时，他们重新开始，德怀特是第一个分享的人。哦，这是我最喜欢的事情之一。
And Dwight shares that he was supposed to have a twin, but he absorbed the twin in utero. All right, we had a fan question from Aira T'Jolly. Did Rainn Wilson make the whole absorbing twin thing up or was it scripted? Well first of all, I will tell you, it is not in the script. I don't know if Rainn made it up, but in the script, Dwight was supposed to say this. He was supposed to say, in the blizzard of 97, 12 shrewds died in the basement of our house. They drank beer cider that had already turned.
德怀特分享说他本来应该有一个双胞胎兄弟，但在子宫里把双胞胎吸收了。好吧，我们有一个来自艾拉·蒂乔利的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊吸收双胞胎的事是自己瞎编的还是剧本里写的？首先，我要告诉你们，剧本里没有这个。我不知道是不是雷恩编的，但在剧本里，德怀特本应该这么说。他本应该说，在97年的暴风雪中，有12只鼩鼱死在我们家的地下室里。它们喝了已经变质的啤酒苹果酒。
But McKinley declared it a national emergency. Now, my favorite thing about that is that clearly it's not 1997. It's like 1897, I guess. But that was originally Dwight's grief share. So here's the thing. I reached out to Jen Salata about this, and this is maybe one of my favorite text threads of all time. This is what tickled me so much is that Jen Salata, Jenna, she's one of our people.
但麦金利宣布这为国家紧急状态。现在，我最喜欢的一点是，这显然不是1997年。我猜大约是1897年。但那原本是德怀特的悲伤分享。所以事情是这样的。我为此联系了詹·萨拉塔，这可能是我有生以来最喜欢的短信串之一。最让我觉得有趣的是，詹·萨拉塔，珍娜，她是我们的朋友。
She's a deep diver. Yeah. The minute I asked her, she went on a deep dive for the whole afternoon. Ready? So I say, okay, Jen, Dwight's speech about absorbing his twin is not in the script. Was that an improv? Did you tell him on the day? She goes, oh my God.
她是个深入研究型的人。是的。我一问她，她整个下午都在深入研究。准备好了吗？所以我说，好吧，詹，德怀特关于吸收双胞胎的演讲不在剧本里。那是即兴发挥吗？你是当天告诉他的吗？她说，哦，天哪。
I don't remember. Oh my God, I love that speech. And sadly, it wasn't mine. I'm going to start texting people. Please hold. Oh, I love this so much. That's happened throughout the day. She said, I texted Rainn.
我不记得了。哦，天哪，我太喜欢那段演讲了。可惜不是我的。我要开始给别人发短信了。请保持。哦，我太喜欢这个了。整天都在发生这种事。她说，我给雷恩发了短信。
Rainn actually thinks it was an alt pitched from Paul. Jen said, here's a side note. I had a friend that reabsorbed his twin, but I definitely didn't come up with the strength of a baby. She said, I'm going to check with Paul where that part came from. Please hold. She texts Paul. Paul says he thinks it was Justin Spitzer.
雷恩其实觉得那是保罗提出的一个备用方案。詹说，顺便说一句，我有一个朋友重新吸收了他的双胞胎，但我绝对没有想出婴儿的力量。她说，我要跟保罗确认一下那段台词是哪里来的。请保持。她给保罗发了短信。保罗说他觉得那是贾斯汀·斯皮策想出来的。
Hold one second. Now texting Justin. Justin was another one of our writers. This is what Justin texted Jen back. I still remember that because it was early season three and I was so nervous about proving myself. I guess, yes, I came up with it. But the thing that really sold it to me was the last line about him having the strength
等一下。现在给贾斯汀发短信。贾斯汀是我们的另一位编剧。这是贾斯汀回给珍的短信。我还记得那个，因为那是第三季早期，我非常紧张，急于证明自己。我想，是的，点子是我出的。但真正说服我的是最后那句关于他拥有成年男子的力量加上一个婴儿的力量。
of a grown man plus a baby. And that was something that Paul Lieberstein added after. So I think he deserves a fair amount of credit as well. So I'm giving that a slow clap into a big clap. Yes. Wow. It was a two-hander that Paul and Justin pitched. I love that we got to the bottom of that mystery because it is one of my all-time favorite
那是保罗·利伯斯坦后来添加的内容。所以我认为他也配得上相当多的功劳。所以我正在为这个鼓掌，从慢速鼓掌到热烈鼓掌。太棒了。哇。这是保罗和贾斯汀共同提出的双人桥段。我很高兴我们弄清了这个谜团的底细，因为这是我历来最喜欢的
Dwightisms. Also, guys, Justin Spitzer is the creator of the show Superstore. Justin is so talented. He's so talented. I love him. Love him. Anyway. I think the only place to go from here is back to our grief circle and we need to hear
德怀特语录之一。还有，伙计们，贾斯汀·斯皮策是电视剧《超级商店》的创作者。贾斯汀太有才了。他太有才了。我爱他。爱死他了。不管怎样。我想从这里出发的唯一地方就是回到我们的哀悼互助会，我们需要听听
from some others. Okay. So we're back into the grief counseling scene and Stanley has just refused. He is not going to participate. He chunks that ball back at Michael. Hey. I heard that. Yeah, you heard that.
其他人的发言。好的。所以我们回到了哀悼辅导的场景，斯坦利刚刚拒绝了。他不会参与。他把那个球砸回给迈克尔。嘿。我听到了。对，你听到了。
I heard that. But Pam agrees to participate and she's going to share a story about her family, but it's clearly just the synopsis for the movie Million Dollar Baby. Yeah. I mean, again, Pam is now the gem. She's the jokester. Yes. And then Ryan joins in and he shares a story that is very clearly the Lion King.
我听到了。但帕姆同意参与，她要分享一个关于她家庭的故事，但这显然只是电影《百万美元宝贝》的剧情简介。对。我的意思是，帕姆现在又是那个宝贝了。她是那个爱开玩笑的人。对。然后瑞安也加入了进来，他分享了一个非常明显的《狮子王》的故事。
I mean, he says the word Mufasa. I mean, come on. But then Kevin catches on and he's tickled. He wants to participate. He wants to play the game, but he goes too broad, too on the nose and he basically breaks down weekend at Bernie's and Michael's like, what? Hold up. That's a movie.
我的意思是，他说出了木法沙这个词。我的意思是，拜托。但接着凯文反应过来了，他觉得很有趣。他想参与。他想玩这个游戏，但他扯得太宽泛、太直白了，他基本上把《伯尼周末》的剧情给剧透了，迈克尔一脸茫然：什么？等等。那是一部电影。
And he gets really ticked off. Okay, so there was a lot of curiosity about these movie plots in the conference room. We got a fan question from Tristan, who wants to know when everyone is in the conference room for Michael's counseling session, did the cast improvise the movie plots that were mentioned or were they scripted? Jenna, to my knowledge, they were all scripted. That's how I remember it. Yes.
他变得非常生气的。好的，所以大家对会议室里的这些电影情节有很多好奇。我们收到了来自特里斯坦的一个粉丝提问，他想知道当大家都在会议室参加迈克尔的辅导课时，演员们是即兴发挥了提到的电影情节，还是有剧本的？珍娜，据我所知，它们全都是有剧本的。我是这么记得的。是的。
I looked these up in the shooting draft and Pam's Million Dollar Baby story and Kevin's weekend at Bernie's story are both in the script, however, Ryan's fake movie story is different. Ah. Yes. In the script, he talks about Thelma and Louise. Well, this is what he says. He says, my mom's sister Thelma died last year.
我在拍摄剧本中查过这些，帕姆的《百万美元宝贝》故事和凯文的《伯尼周末》故事都在剧本里，然而，瑞安的假电影故事是不同的。啊。是的。在剧本里，他谈到的是《末路狂花》。好吧，他是这么说的。他说，我妈妈的妹妹塞尔玛去年去世了。
She was with her friend named Lucy. A cop was trying to pull them over and I guess the brakes must have not been working because they ended up driving over a cliff and it was a total shock to everyone. Okay. Well, we wanted to get to the bottom of this, so we reached out to the source, the writer of this episode, Jen Salada, and this is what she had to say. For the movies in the grief counseling session, I was really excited. It was really fun to think about.
她和她的一个叫露西的朋友在一起。一个警察试图把他们拦下来，我猜刹车一定失灵了，因为他们最后把车开下了悬崖，这对所有人来说都是一个巨大的震惊。好吧。嗯，我们想弄个水落石出，所以我们联系了源头，本集的编剧珍·萨拉达，她是这么说的。对于哀悼辅导会里的电影，我真的很兴奋。想起来真的很有趣。
I went off on script and needed to find a way that everybody would sit there with Michael Scott and not share their own personal stories of huge loss because it just didn't seem like they would do that. So I thought they should share movies, plot lines as if they were their own lives. And I came up with million dollar baby for Eugenia for Pam and then also for Kevin weekend at Bernie's. And for Ryan, I had a different one, I think BJ came up with the Lion King. I don't quite remember, but I think it was BJ and I love that one.
我偏离了剧本，需要找到一种方法，让每个人都坐在迈克尔·斯科特身边，而不会分享他们自己关于巨大损失的个人故事，因为他们似乎不会那样做。所以我认为他们应该分享电影情节，就好像那是他们自己的生活一样。我为尤金尼亚也就是帕姆想出了《百万美元宝贝》，然后也为凯文想到了《伯尼周末》。至于瑞安，我有一个不同的，我想比杰想出了《狮子王》。我记不太清了，但我想是比杰，我超喜欢那个。
The one I had, I actually found my first draft of the script. I had Ryan, I'll read you the line. It's not as good as the Lion King one, but I have Ryan say, this is almost too horrible to talk about, but I had a cousin who was a big city lawyer and he was visiting an Amish town not far from here and he was smothered to death in their grain silo. And then I had Michael say, ooh, that must have made you really sad. Did it? And Ryan says yes.
我原本选的那一个，我居然找到了剧本的第一稿。我有瑞安的，我读给你听台词。它没有《狮子王》那个好，但我让瑞安说，这几乎太可怕了，无法启齿，但我有个表弟是个大城市律师，他当时正在离这不远的一个阿米什小镇参观，结果他在他们的谷仓里被闷死了。然后我让迈克尔说，哦，那一定让你很难过吧？是吗？然后瑞安说，是的。
So I think that was a witness. So I had Ryan's from witness. I wish I could remember some of the other ones because I feel like we had other ones that we pitched on, but those were the ones from my first draft. And then of course the Lion King Circle of Life was fantastic and Ryan saying it'll take about an hour and a half to tell it was like such a great line. That is amazing. By the way, my college roommate and I used to watch witness and we would say to each
所以我想那是个证人。所以我把瑞安的设定为《目击者》。我要是能记住其他的一些就好了，因为我觉得我们还有其他讨论过的方案，但那些是我第一稿里的。然后当然《狮子王》的生生不息太棒了，瑞安说这大概需要一个半小时才能讲完，真是一句绝妙的台词。太棒了。顺便说一句，我和我的大学室友以前经常看《目击者》，我们俩会经常对
other all the time, be careful out among them English. Thank you. That is my movie quote from witness. But isn't that wild Jenna that Ryan's, Ryan's movie went through three versions. It was witness. And then it was, I guess, Thelma and Louise, according to your script, but the Lion King is what made it in the show. Yeah.
彼此说，在那些英国佬当中要小心点。谢谢。那是我对《目击者》的电影台词引用。但是珍娜，难道不觉得疯狂吗，瑞安的电影经历了三个版本。它是《目击者》。然后它是，我猜，根据你的剧本是《末路狂花》，但最终出现在剧中的是《狮子王》。是的。
Clearly they had a lot of alts for these movie plots, but all of them were scripted guys. All of them written by our awesome writers. We did not improvise that stuff. Love that. Love that little tidbit, Jen Slotta. So guys, Michael gets pretty upset that people are not taking this seriously. You know, he says the guy who used to do his job and sit at his desk has died and no one
显然他们对这些电影情节有很多备选项，但所有这些都是有剧本的，伙计们。全都是由我们优秀的编剧写的。我们并没有即兴发挥那些东西。太棒了。喜欢这个小花絮，珍·萨拉达。所以伙计们，迈克尔对大家没有认真对待这件事感到相当沮丧。你知道，他说那个以前做他工作并坐在他座位上的人已经死了，而没有人
cares. And Toby tries to talk him down and tries to explain that this is just life and that this morning he saw a bird fly into the window downstairs and die. Michael freaks out. Oh my gosh, Toby, Toby, what are you thinking? He totally attaches to that. Now Michael's grief for Ed is somehow wrapped into this bird. It's going to be a whole thing.
在乎。托比试图安抚他，并试图解释说这就是生活，他今天早上看到一只鸟飞进楼下的窗户然后死了。迈克尔吓坏了。哦天哪，托比，托比，你在想什么？他完全把这件事联系在一起了。现在迈克尔对埃德的悲伤不知怎么地包裹进了这只鸟身上。这将会没完没了。
Yeah. He runs downstairs. He freaks out. He wants to see if the bird is alive. I had a fan catch here from Kendra. At 14 minutes 33 seconds when Michael runs through the front door to get the bird, he runs past the security desk and the security guard is not Hank. Oh, good catch.
是的。他跑下楼。他吓坏了。他想看看那只鸟是不是还活着。我这里收到了肯德拉的一个粉丝抓包。在14分33秒时，当迈克尔冲过前门去拿那只鸟时，他跑过了安保桌，而那个保安不是汉克。哦，好眼尖。
Yeah, different security guard. Hank took a personal day, you guys. I guess so. Well, Michael attempts to resuscitate the bird in the kitchen. Angela, you're not pleased. So Michael is determined to save this bird. He brings it into the kitchen. Angela Martin is not pleased.
是的，是不同的保安。汉克请了一天个人假，伙计们。我猜是的。好吧，迈克尔试图在厨房里对这只鸟进行心肺复苏，安吉拉，你可不高兴了。所以迈克尔决心要救这只鸟。他把它带进了厨房。安吉拉·马丁可不高兴了。
She's like, no, that shouldn't be in here. Get it out. Well, she is not pleased and Angela, she's not wrong. Thank you. Thank you, Jenna. You're welcome. You're welcome. We had a fan question from Ellie Friedlander.
她说，不，那不应该在这里。拿出去。好吧，她非常不高兴而且安吉拉，她并没有错。谢谢。谢谢你，珍娜。不客气。不客气。我们收到了来自埃利·弗里德兰德的粉丝提问。
She wants to know, was that a real dead bird? No. No. No, Ellie. It was a fake bird. I reached out to Phil. He told me that he found three dead fake bird options and presented them to Jen, Roger, our director, and Greg.
她想知道，那是一只真的死鸟吗？不是。不。不，埃利。那是一只假鸟。我联系了菲尔。他告诉他找到了三个死假鸟选项，并把它们呈给了珍、我们的导演罗杰和格雷格。
They chose the one that you see in the show. And Angela, I have to say, when he texted me back that he presented the three dead birds, I imagined in my head that they were on a silver tray, because remember, Phil would always present you your props on a silver tray. Yes. Yes. And I was just imagining it. And I wrote it back and I said, Phil, were they on a silver tray?
他们选择了你在剧中看到的那一个。安吉拉，我不得不说，当他回短信说他展示了三只死鸟时，我在脑海里想象它们放在一个银盘上，因为记得吗，菲尔总是会把你的道具放在一个银盘上呈上来。是的。是的。我当时就在想象那个画面。我回信说，菲尔，它们是在银盘上吗？
And he said, you know me too well. These are the moments in our show where I'm like, hey, babe, how was your day? What'd you do today? Well, I had to find three fake dead birds. Yeah. I scoured. Or like when Greg goes home and his wife, Susie, is like, hey, hon, how'd it go shooting today?
他说，你太了解我了。这些就是我们剧里让我觉得，嘿，宝贝，你今天过得怎么样？你今天干嘛了？哦，我得去找三只假死鸟。啊。我四处搜寻。或者就像格雷格回家时，他的妻子苏茜说，嘿，亲爱的，今天拍摄怎么样？
He's like, great. I picked a dead bird. Yeah. I picked the yellow one. I made my dead bird selection. Yes. Exactly. Well, Michael then tells the staff, attention, attention, we are holding a funeral for this
他说，挺好。我挑了一只死鸟。对。我挑了黄的那只。我做出了我的死鸟选择。是的。完全正确。好吧，迈克尔随后告诉全体员工，注意，注意，我们将在下午4点在停车场为这只鸟举行葬礼
bird at 4 p.m. in the parking lot. Be there. It's on. Jenna, now I think it's time to check back in on Jim and Karen. Oh, yes. Have they found the chips? Where are they? Where are they in their search for this very hard to find potato chip bag?
。务必出席。就这么定了。珍娜，现在我觉得是时候回过头来看看吉姆和凯伦了。哦，对了。他们找到薯片了吗？他们在哪里？他们在这个极难找到的薯片袋的搜寻中进展到哪一步了？
That's actually in the vending machine. That might be in the vending machine. That is in the vending machine. That according to a fan catch is B1 in the vending machine. Yeah. It's right there waiting for them. Well, Karen kind of impresses Jim because she decides to call Montreal, the Montreal factory to see if they have them, and she speaks French.
其实就在自动售货机里。那可能在自动售货机里。那就在自动售货机里。根据一个粉丝的抓包，那是自动售货机里的B1。是的。它就在那里等着他们呢。好吧，凯伦给吉姆留下了深刻的印象，因为她决定给蒙特利尔打电话，打给蒙特利尔工厂看看他们有没有，而且她会说法语。
May we? May we? May we? A lot of people wrote in about this. Breanna Bullard and many, many others want to know, does Rashida Jones actually know French? So, I texted Rashida since we're already texting about her breakfast order. She's probably like, Angela, what is happening? This is what she said.
我们可以吗？我们可以吗？我们可以吗？很多人写信来问这件事。布里安娜·布拉德和许许多多其他人想知道，瑞希·威瑟斯彭，不对，是瑞希·杰姆斯，真的会说法语吗？所以，我给瑞希发了短信，因为我们已经在讨论她的早餐订单了。她可能会想，安吉拉，到底发生什么事了？她是这么说的。
She goes, no, at this time, I didn't know French. I worked really hard on that line. But a few years later, I ended up going to France to do a French immersion school in the south of France. Maybe this scene was the beginning and it got me inspired. Wow. That's crazy. She did not speak French, but now she does.
她说，不，当时我不会法语。我对那句台词下了很大功夫。但几年后，我最终去了法国，在法国南部的一所法语沉浸式学校学习。也许这个场景是开始，它启发了我。哇。这太疯狂了。她以前不会说法语，但现在会了。
Yes. I was like, I want to go to a French immersion class in the south of France. That sounds amazing. Same. Same. I took French in high school. You did? Oh, I have a story about that, actually.
对。当时我就想，我想去法国南部的法语沉浸班。听起来太棒了。我也是。我也是。我高中学过法语。你学过？哦，其实我关于这个有个故事。
Yeah. Can I tell this real quickly? Yeah. I took French in high school from Sister Landry. I went to a Catholic school. Sister Landry was my French teacher. And I dreamed, I told you guys this before, I dreamed from the time I was a little girl that I would one day go to Paris.
是吗。我能快速讲一下吗？行。我高中时跟兰德里修女学过法语。我上的是天主教学校。兰德里修女是我的法语老师。我一直梦想着——我以前跟你们说过——从小时候起，我就梦想有一天能去巴黎。
And then in my 30s that finally happened, of course, at this point, I was now very far from my French training. Couldn't really speak French. But Lee and I, we went to a little farmer's market and I guess in France, you don't touch the fruit. Uh-oh. Okay? You don't select your own produce.
然后在我30多岁的时候，这终于实现了。当然，到了这个时候，我已经把法语忘得差不多了。其实已经不会说法语了。但我和李去了一个小农贸市场，我猜在法国，你是不能碰水果的。哦哦。好吧？你不能自己挑农产品。
You don't point to it or you trust the person selling the produce to select the best pieces for you. I didn't know this, okay? Oh my gosh. I would have been, I pick up things, I thump them, I smell them. No, lady. Don't do it. Uh-oh.
你不能指着它，或者你得信任卖农产品的人，让他们为你挑选最好的部分。我不知道这个，好吧？哦天哪。如果是我的话，我会去拿东西，我会捏捏它们，我会闻闻它们。不，女士。别这么做。哦哦。
If you go to a farmer's market in France, here's my hot tip for you. Don't thump the melon. Do not touch that fruit. Don't thump the melon. Don't thump the melon in France, okay? Okay. Now, all through this trip, we'd been going to restaurants and we'd been going to tourist places and I was just fumbling with my French.
如果你去法国的农贸市场，这是我给你的诚意建议。不要捏那个甜瓜。绝对不要碰那个水果。不要捏那个甜瓜。在法国不要捏甜瓜，好吗？好的。好了，在这次旅行中，我们一直去餐馆，去旅游景点，我一直在笨拙地使用我的法语。
I couldn't get anything out. I could read the menus, but I couldn't order anything. I was, I thought I was going to really help us, but I couldn't help us. But here we are. We're at this little market. I have done the faux pas, I believe that's French, the faux pas of touching the fruit. And this woman turns to her coworker and goes off on me. She in French is calling me like, kind of like a dumb American.
我什么也说不出来。我能看懂菜单，但我什么也点不了。我当时觉得我能帮上大忙，但我根本帮不上忙。但现在，我们在那。我们在那个小市场上。我犯了禁忌，我想那是法语，触碰水果的禁忌。这个女人转向她的同事，对我大发雷霆。她用法语把我骂了一顿，有点像在骂一个愚蠢的美国人。
Your piece of trash. Yeah, basically whatever it was, just these Americans come here and they touch her fruit. She was like going on, okay, in French. I was this mixture of just like embarrassed, but also felt like, I'm sorry, how was I supposed to know that? I'm, I'm a nice person. I'm not a bad person. I'm sorry, I picked up that banana and Angela, this fluent French spilled out of my mouth
你这个垃圾。是的，基本上不管是什么，就是这些美国人来到这里然后碰她的水果。她就在那里喋喋不休，用法语说。我当时的心情真是既尴尬，又觉得：对不起，我怎么可能知道这个？我是个好人。我不是坏人。对不起，我拿了那个香蕉。然后安吉拉，流利的法语从我嘴里倾泻而出，
at this woman. And in French, I suddenly had the command to say, I'm so sorry, but in the United States, we pick our own fruit. I didn't know about your custom. I apologize, but you don't need to say nasty things about me. And the look on her face was like, oh, because she certainly didn't think that the fruit touching American could speak French or understand French. And by the way, I didn't know that I had such a command of the language until I was insulted
冲着这个女人。而我突然用意大利语——我是说法语，有能力说：非常抱歉，但在美国，我们都是自己挑水果的。我不知道你们的风俗。我道歉，但你没必要说那么难听的话。而她脸上的表情就像是“哦”，因为她绝对没想到这个会碰水果的美国人居然会说法语或听懂法语。顺便说一句，我甚至不知道自己对这门语言有这么好的掌控力，直到我在巴黎的一个农贸市场被人侮辱。
in a farmer's market in Paris. And then your superpower came out. Yes. You know how like some, some superheroes, their power doesn't come through until they're in crisis. That's, I was like a mom lifting a car off her baby. Yeah, exactly. So now we're back at Dunder Mifflin and Kelly is crying by the copier in the annex.
然后你的超能力就爆发了。是的。你知道有些超级英雄的力量只有在危机时刻才会显现出来吗。那就是，我就像一个母亲把车从她宝宝身上抬起来一样。对，完全是这样。所以现在我们回到了邓德米夫林，凯莉正在附楼的复印机旁哭泣。
Yeah. She is in tears. Michael thinks he's finally made a breakthrough until she reveals that she's really crying about her plans with Ryan. I have a question about this scene. Okay. What is up with this second copier in the annex? Is it always there?
是的。她泪流满面。迈克尔以为他终于有了突破，直到她透露她其实是为了和瑞恩的计划在哭。我关于这个场景有个问题。好的。附楼里的这第二台复印机是怎么回事？它一直都在那里吗？
I have never seen it before. What is happening? I think they just rolled it in from the bullpen for the scene. I feel like they did and they did it because in the background, in the break room Dwight is in there. You can see him over Kelly's shoulder trying to shove this bird into an empty soda can. I feel like that's why they had to put the copier there to combine these two moments to have a reason for Michael to be back there.
我以前从来没见过它。这是怎么回事？我觉得他们只是为了这个场景把它从大办公室推过来的。我觉得他们确实这么做了，因为在背景中，在休息室里，德怀特在那。你可以从凯莉的肩膀上看过去，看到他正试图把这只鸟塞进一个空苏打罐里。我觉得这就是他们必须把复印机放在那里的原因，为了把这两个时刻结合起来，给迈克尔一个去那里的理由。
Right. And for him to see over his shoulder and all of that, exactly that copier did not live there in that hallway. They just shoved it there. Yeah. I think so. I feel like I will track this. It's going to be a soft track, but I am going to look for this copier more.
对。为了让他能从肩膀上方看过去以及所有这些，确实那台复印机平时并不住在那个走廊里。他们只是把它硬塞到那里的。对。我也这么觉得。我觉得我会追踪这个。这将是一个冷门追踪，但我会更多地寻找这台复印机。
I think it should be a very soft track because I would be bold enough to say I think it might be the only time it's in the annex. I know that's setting myself up for some fan mail of like Angela actually in season eight, but I'm just saying I don't think that copier visits the annex very often. Guys, if you're watching another episode and you see that copier right to us, you can go to our website, OfficeLadies.com and submit questions or comments or write to us at OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com. Okay. Here we go.
我觉得这应该是一个非常冷门的追踪，因为我敢大言不惭地说，我觉得这可能是它唯一一次出现在附楼里。我知道这会给我招来一些粉丝来信，比如安吉拉，其实在第八季里……但我只是说，我觉得那台复印机不常去附楼。伙计们，如果你在看另一集时看到了那台复印机，写信给我们，你可以访问我们的网站 OfficeLadies.com 并提交问题或评论，或者发邮件到 OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com。好了。我们开始吧。
We want to know. We want to know. All right, but this leads us into one of my favorite white talking heads where he explains he's justifying why is he shoving this bird into a can and it's because he grew up on a farm. Yeah. And guys, they reburied his grandfather in an old oil drum. Okay.
我们想知道。我们想知道。好吧，但这把我们引入了德怀特最喜欢的访谈片段之一，他在其中解释、辩解他为什么要将这只鸟塞进罐子里，这是因为他在农场长大的。对。而且伙计们，他们把他的祖父重新埋在了一个旧油桶里。好吧。
Hold on. I mean, the same grandfather that was buried in the suit that he wore, like what's happening? How many times has this guy been brought up out of the ground? This is one of my favorite things about our show. Teresa S. also loves it. She wrote in to say, in Casino Night, Dwight says that his grandfather was buried in the tuxedo he's wearing. Yeah.
等等。我是说，就是那个穿着他生前穿的西装下葬的爷爷？这算怎么回事？这家伙被从地里挖出来多少次了？这是我们节目中我最喜欢的事情之一。特蕾莎·S也很喜欢。她写信说，在《赌场之夜》中，德怀特说他的祖父穿着他身上这套燕尾服下葬。对。
And in grief counseling, he said his grandfather was reburied in an oil drum. Yeah. Reburied? What? She wrote reburied. What happened? Don't worry behind Dwight's grandfather. Was he exhumed for some reason?
而在《哀伤辅导》中，他说他的祖父被重新埋在一个油桶里。对。重新埋葬？什么？她写的是重新埋葬。发生了什么？别在意德怀特的祖父背后发生了什么。他是不是因为某种原因被掘墓棺了？
And did Dwight take the tuxedo off his dead grandfather before reburying him? And then fold him up? It sounds like it. Then he folded him up and tried to shove him in a drum. Teresa, that's exactly what it sounds like. This is some of my favorite writing on our show in that moment in Casino Night when Dwight just says he's wearing a tuxedo, my grandfather was buried in it. That's it.
而且德怀特在重新安葬他的死去的祖父之前，是不是把燕尾服从他身上脱下来了？然后把它折叠起来？听起来是这样的。然后他把它折叠起来，试图把它塞进一个桶里。特蕾莎，听起来确实就是这样。这是我们节目中我最喜欢的剧本编写之一，在《赌场之夜》的那个时刻，德怀特只是说他穿着燕尾服，我爷爷就是穿着它下葬的。就这样。
We say no more about it. Three episodes later, he's like when my grandfather was reburied and it's like slowly it's all coming together, sort of, sort of, not completely, is one of my favorite bits of how our show is written. So now we're at reception, right? And Pam has prepared this really beautiful box for the bird funeral. I mean, it is amazing, the attention to detail. She asked Dwight if he would perhaps want to play a song.
我们对此闭口不谈。三集之后，他就像当我的爷爷被重新安葬时……这就好像它慢慢地汇集到了一起，某种程度上，某种程度上，又没有完全汇集，这是我们节目的剧本创作中我最喜欢的桥段之一。所以现在我们在前台，对吧？然后帕姆为鸟的葬礼准备了这个非常漂亮的盒子。我是说，太惊人了，对细节的关注。她问德怀特是否也许想演奏一首歌。
She's like, do you have your recorder? He's like, always, always, always, always. And you know, Pam has this really sweet talking head where she's like, well, you know what? I didn't anticipate I'd be throwing a bird funeral today, but you never know, working here. That's right. We had a fan question from Andrew S. Did Jenna make the box for the bird funeral herself or was that a Phil Shea creation?
她说：你带竖笛了吗？他说：随时，随时，随时，随时。你知道的，帕姆有一个非常温馨的访谈，她说：好吧，你知道吗？我没想到我今天会办一场鸟的葬礼，但在工作时，你永远不知道会发生什么。没错。我们有一个来自安德鲁·S的粉丝问题。詹娜是自己为鸟的葬礼做了那个盒子，还是那是菲尔·谢伊的作品？
Either way, how was it constructed? Well, guys, I did not make it. Phil Shea made it. He said he actually made a few options and presented them again to Jen and Roger and Greg. They picked the one that they liked. And then Phil had to make multiples of it because, you know, it gets set on fire. Yeah.
不管怎样，它是怎么制作的？好吧，伙计们，不是我做的。是菲尔·谢伊做的。他说他其实做了几个选择，然后再次向詹、罗杰和格雷格展示。他们选了他们喜欢的那个。然后菲尔不得不制作好几个复制品，因为，你知道的，它被烧掉了。对。
So he had to make a whole bunch of those. I looked it up in the script and it was described in the script. So here's what Phil had to go off of. It said, it is a hollowed out tissue box with tissue padding in the center for the bird to lie on and the outside is decorated in tissue paper and has a tiny little toothpick cross. My favorite part are the the handles, the handles made out of the pencils. So that was a Phil addition.
所以他不得不制作一大堆那种盒子。我在剧本里查了一下，剧本里有描述。所以这是菲尔需要遵循的内容：它是一个掏空的纸巾盒，中间有纸巾衬垫供小鸟躺在上面，外面用纸巾装饰，还有一个极小的牙签十字架。我最喜欢的部分是把手，用铅笔做成的把手。所以那是菲尔的巧思。
That was just Phil. Yeah. Yeah. He needed to make sure that tiny bird casket had little bars for his, the pallbearers. That's right. The tiny, the tiny pallbearers. Yes. They are going to wrap things up in Stamford now.
那纯粹是菲尔的创意。对。对。他需要确保那个微型鸟棺材有小栏杆，给抬棺人用的。没错。微型，微型抬棺人。是的。他们现在要在斯坦福把事情做个了结了。
Guys, Jim found the chips. He left them on her desk. He's quite pleased with himself. Yeah. I really wanted my mom to record a sting that said, flirty Jim, but we, we couldn't, we couldn't get it together. Oh, well these scenes drove people crazy. I went back and looked at some of the comments from when this air.
伙计们，吉姆找到了薯片。他把它们留在了她的桌上。他对自己的表现相当满意。对。我真的很想让我妈妈录一段音效，说“调情的吉姆”，但我们，我们没能弄成。哦，好吧，这些场景把人们迷得神魂颠倒。我回去看了一些当这集播出时的评论。
Here is what they said. D temp said, I feel kind of weird about Jim and Karen, but Hartman said, uh, the Karen thing. Why, oh, why am I liking it? But I am. Whoa. I remember people freaking out about it. Well, Keely said, Jim and Karen have great chemistry.
以下是他们的说法。D temp 说：我对吉姆和凯伦感觉有点怪怪的，但哈特曼说：呃，关于凯伦的事。为什么，哦，为什么我会喜欢它？但我确实喜欢。哇。我记得人们对此疯狂热议。好吧，凯利说：吉姆和凯伦很有化学反应。
And Mandy said, okay, I'm sorry. I can't believe there are actually people out there who are okay with Jim hooking up with Karen. That's what I remember. But Kim E said this, hmm, Jim likes to buy chips for all his ladies. And I'm with you, Kim, as Pam, I'm like, Oh, is this what you do? You just find all the girls their favorite chips. Yeah.
曼迪说：好吧，我很抱歉。我真不敢相信居然真的有人能接受吉姆和凯伦搞在一起。这就是我所记得的。但金·E说这个，嗯，吉姆喜欢为他所有的女人们买薯片。我和你同感，金，作为帕姆，我就像是在想，哦，这就是你的惯用伎俩吗？你就是去帮所有的女孩找她们最喜欢的薯片。对。
That's his game. Are we saying that right? Oh, is that you're doing I, I 100% sure we are Sam's giving us an okay. Sam gave us an okay. That's his game. All right. Should we go to this bird funeral, Angela? I can't wait.
这就是他的把戏。我们说得对吗？哦，这是你在干的事吗？我百分之百确定我们……山姆给我们比了个ok。山姆给我们比了个ok。这就是他的把戏。好吧。我们要去参加这个鸟的葬礼吗，安吉拉？我等不及了。
Please take me there. Well, we're out in the driveway, really next to the warehouse. This was a, an actual parking lot that we used and it was right next to the warehouse and that's where we filmed this. Michael is very moved by Pam's beautiful coffin. It starts with Pam saying a few words about the bird, but we, we slowly realized that Pam is speaking about the bird that she's speaking to Michael about his feelings about death and loss and about his aloneness.
请带我去那儿吧。好吧，我们在车道上，其实就在仓库旁边。这是一个我们用过的实际停车场，它紧挨着仓库，这就是我们拍摄它的地方。迈克尔被帕姆美丽的棺材深深打动了。开场是帕姆对小鸟说了几句话，但我们，我们渐渐意识到帕姆其实是在谈论那只鸟，她是在对迈克尔倾诉他对死亡和失去的感觉，以及关于他的孤独。
She talks a lot about how just because the bird was alone, doesn't mean he was unloved, that he was very loved and respected by the other birds. And then she sings a song. I was very surprised by this for Pam. She really put herself out there. She sings on the wings of love. She's accompanied by Dwight on the recorder. Michael is very moved.
她谈了许多关于仅仅因为这只鸟很孤独并不意味着它不被爱，它被其他鸟儿深深地爱着和尊重着。然后她唱了一首歌。我对帕姆的这个举动感到非常惊讶。她真的豁出去了。她唱了《在爱的翅膀上》（On the Wings of Love）。德怀特用竖笛给她伴奏。迈克尔非常感动。
He's holding hands. He's swaying. He's tearing up. We got a lot of questions about this scene. Richard H. really covers them all. He says, did Rain already know how to play the recorder? Did Jenna sing the entire song? Or did the singing end where the scene was cut?
他拉着手。他左右摇晃。他热泪盈眶。我们收到了很多关于这个场景的问题。理查德·H 真的把这些问题都涵盖了。他说：雷恩之前就会吹竖笛吗？詹娜是唱了整首歌吗？还是歌声在场景被剪辑的地方就结束了？
He also wanted to know, did we rehearse our duet? Here's what I can tell you. Yes. Rain knew how to play the recorder. Remember he played it in Take Your Daughter to Work Day. He's actually very good. But listen to all of the instruments that Rain can play in real life, Angela. He can play the recorder, piano, clarinet, saxophone, bassoon, guitar, drums, xylophone,
他还想知道，我们排练过我们的二重唱吗？这就是我能告诉你的。是的。雷恩会吹竖笛。记得他在《带女儿上班日》里吹过吗。他其实吹得很好。但听听雷恩在现实生活中会演奏的所有乐器吧，安吉拉。他会吹竖笛、钢琴、单簧管、萨克斯、巴松管、吉他、架子鼓、木琴、
bells, and a little tuba and baritone. What are you, a one-man band, Rain? How it is! How I knew you could play the bassoon because your book, The Bassoon King, is great. So I knew that, but I didn't know you were walking one-man show. Suffice it to say, Rain knew his stuff. And we did rehearse, but just a little bit right before the scene. Rain and I practiced separately.
铃铛，还有一点大号和次中音号。你是什么，一人乐队吗，雷恩？太厉害了！我怎么知道你会吹巴松管的，因为你的书《巴松管之王》很棒。所以我知道那个，但我不知道你是个行走的独角戏演员。简而言之，雷恩是个行家。而且我们排练过，就在场景拍摄前稍微排练了一下。雷恩和我分开练习。
I had listened to the song over and over again to memorize the words. I had to sing the first verse through the chorus. That's what I had to do over and over again. I was so nervous. Well, I thought you did fantastic. Thank you. I have a fan question from the scene, Jenna. Okay.
我把这首歌听了一遍又一遍来记住歌词。我得从第一段主歌一直唱到副歌。这就是我一遍又一遍必须做的事。我当时紧张极了。好吧，我觉得你表现得棒极了。谢谢。我有一个关于这个场景的粉丝问题，詹娜。好的。
So Chelsea wrote in and said, was Angela's a man improvised? A lot of people wrote in about this because it was so quick after Pam has done talking. People wanted to know if I improvised that. No, that was scripted. And folks wanted to know why did Angela do it? And I said, I think personally, the direction that, you know, they gave me was that Angela had had enough of this charade, this bird funeral, Pam had gone on and on, enough. Amen.
所以切尔西写信问：安吉拉的那句“够了”（Amen）是即兴发挥的吗？很多人写信来问这个，因为在帕姆说完话后它来得太快了。人们想知道那是不是我即兴发挥的。不，那是剧本里写好的。大家想知道为什么安吉拉要这么做？我说，我个人认为，他们给我的指导方向是，安吉拉受够了这场闹剧、这个鸟的葬礼，帕姆说个没完没了，够了。阿门。
I'm done. And that's... That's how you finish it. Yes. Amen. Amen. I'm finished. Amen.
我受够了。那就是……那就是你结束它的方式。是的。阿门。阿门。我结束了。阿门。
Stop talking. Yes, exactly. Speaking of the script, I have a script catch. Okay. So, you know, in the scene, we set the box on fire. In the shooting draft of the script, we buried the bird. There was a scene where Michael and Dwight are digging a hole outside and then we all gather around this hole and it got changed to fire, but I don't know why.
别说了。是的，完全是这样。说到剧本，我发现了一个剧本穿帮。好的。所以，你知道的，在场景中，我们把盒子点燃了。在拍摄草稿剧本中，我们是把鸟埋了。原本有一个场景是迈克尔和德怀特在外面挖一个洞，然后我们全都聚集在这个洞周围，后来被改成火化了，但我不知道为什么。
I think maybe Angela, there was really no grass in this area that we shot. We had no grass. There was a hedge with maybe like, I don't know, three feet of dirt. Like, yeah. There was, I mean, not even, there is a deleted scene where Michael and Dwight are trying to dig a hole there and then the business on the other side yells at them and they run away. Oh, okay.
我想也许是，安吉拉，我们拍摄的这个区域真的没有草。我们没有草。那里只有一道树篱，大概有，我不知道，三英尺的泥土。就像是，是的。我的意思是，甚至都没有，有一个被删减的场景，迈克尔和德怀特试图在那里挖一个洞，然后另一边的企业员工对他们大喊大叫，他们就跑开了。哦，好吧。
Okay. Well, there you go. Well, we had another fan question about this fire then. Clara Johnson wants to know, did you actually set the bird on fire? Yes. Real fire, fake bird. Kent told me they had to hire a special effects guy to oversee the fire and the extinguishing and they had to get a special permit to be allowed to set the fire.
好吧，原来如此。好吧，关于这场火，我们还有一个粉丝问题。克拉拉·约翰逊想知道，你们真的把那只鸟点着了吗？是的。真火，假鸟。肯特告诉我，他们不得不雇佣一个特效人员来监督火灾和灭火工作，他们还必须获得一个特别许可才能被允许生火。
And he said we did three takes, three takes of the fire. And Phil told me though that the special effects guys were worried that the fake dead bird might give off toxic fumes when it burned. So we, they actually took it out of the box and just put a wad of toilet paper in there. Oh, not toilet paper. I know. Too soon. I know.
他说我们拍了三次，关于火的三次拍摄。不过菲尔告诉我，特效人员担心假死鸟在燃烧时可能会释放出有毒气体。所以我们，他们实际上把它从盒子里拿出来了，只在里面塞了一团卫生纸。哦，不是卫生纸。我知道。为时过早。我知道。
Too soon, Angela. Too soon. And then finally, we had a fan catch from Peter Kay. He said, I noticed the box was burned in some shredded paper. Could this be further evidence that Pam does use the shredder? Oh, look at that. Nice one, Peter. It would appear so.
太早了，安吉拉。太早了。然后最后，我们收到了彼得·凯的一个粉丝发现。他说：我注意到盒子是在一些碎纸里烧掉的。这会不会进一步证明帕姆确实用了碎纸机？哦，看那个。干得漂亮，彼得。看来是的。
Well, you know, Jen actually left us a really great message about this scene and she was talking about the fact that we never got to shoot outside. And when we did, everyone would get really excited and she explains a little bit about that. How can you play that? One thing that I remember from the grief counseling episode is that when I went to the sound mix, they were showing us the playback of the episode and it was still a little bit unusual when the characters went outside.
好吧，你知道的，詹其实给我们留了一条非常棒的关于这个场景的信息，她谈到了这样一个事实：我们从来没有机会去室外拍摄。而当我们去室外时，每个人都会非常兴奋，她对此做了一些解释。你怎么能播放那个呢？关于哀伤辅导那一集，我记得的一件事是，当我去看声音混音时，他们正在给我们播放这一集的母带，当角色们走到户外时，感觉还是有点不寻常。
It was still a little bit of a treat. So we get to this bird funeral scene and our characters are outside and I just remember hearing kind of an enormous amount of birds and I think that it was because we were outside. It was because we had a bird funeral. It was so exciting for the amazing sound people who do a fantastic job to put a lot of bird noises in because for the longest time when we're inside the office, they're just putting dot matrix printer sounds and just faxes and old fashioned office noises. So it must have been such a treat and a field day to be able to go outside and hear birds
这仍然算是一种小小的款待。所以我们到了这个鸟的葬礼场景，我们的角色在户外，我只记得听到了一种数量巨大的鸟叫声，我想这是因为我们在户外。是因为我们举办了一场鸟的葬礼。对于那些做着了不起工作的出色音响师来说，把大量的鸟叫声放进去是如此令人兴奋，因为很长一段时间以来，当我们呆在办公室里时，他们只是在放入点阵打印机的声音，仅仅是传真机和老式的办公室噪音。所以能够去户外听到鸟叫声，一定是一种极大的款待和盛宴，
and especially on theme with the funeral. So I remember it was a slight exaggeration, but it sounded a little bit like Alfred Hitchcock, the birds when I first heard the playback for the bird funeral. But they quickly made a wonderful adjustment and it was the right amount of outside birds. I love that. I love that our sound mixers got so excited. They put like hundreds of birds and they're like, okay, guys, there's not as many birds outside.
尤其是与葬礼的主题相呼应。所以我记得这有点夸张，但当我第一次听到鸟类葬礼的回放时，听起来有点像阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的《群鸟》。但他们很快做出了绝妙的调整，那是适量的户外鸟鸣。我喜欢这个。我喜欢我们的混音师如此兴奋。他们放了成百上千只鸟，然后他们说：好吧，伙计们，外面没有那么多鸟。
Let's dial it back. Yes. Yes. Oh, what good insight from Jen this week. Yes. Thank you so much, Jen Salata, for sending in those clips and for texting me. You are amazing. We so appreciate it.
让我们把它调小一点。是的。是的。哦，本周詹带来了多么深刻的见解啊。是的。非常感谢你，詹·索拉塔，给我们发来这些剪辑并给我发短信。你太棒了。我们非常感激。
And thank you, Rashida, for letting me bug you about all kinds of random things yesterday. And also Phil Shea and Kent Sabornak. Thank you guys for helping us make this podcast so great. And thanks so much to Mindy Kaling for letting us take a clip from your book. Is everyone hanging out without me and other concerns? It's hilarious. We love you, Mindy. So there you have it, guys.
也谢谢雷希达，昨天让我为各种各样随机的事情烦扰你。还有菲尔·谢伊和肯特·萨博纳克。谢谢你们帮我们把这个播客做得这么棒。非常感谢明迪·卡林让我们摘录你书中的一个片段。每个人都在没有我的情况下出去玩吗以及其他担忧？太搞笑了。我们爱你，明迪。所以，就是这样，伙计们。
That's the grief counseling episode. Did we do it? Are we leaving you depressed? I hope not. And hopefully, next week, we won't have any more dead birds to tell you about in our lives. Stay safe out there, flying friends. Stay safe out there, everyone. We love you.
这就是《哀伤辅导》那一集。我们做到了吗？我们是不是让你们感到沮丧了？希望没有。希望下周我们的生活中不会再有死鸟要告诉你们了。在外面注意安全，飞行的朋友们。大家在外面都要注意安全。我们爱你们。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。有关 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。